what's going on man can you hear us
what's up yeah i can hear you can hear
me
so this is the fella that uh we talked
about last week
invited uh theo out to go fishing in
nashville
what's up bro i owe you a big apology
first of all because we accidentally put
your phone number on the episode
yeah yeah yeah we just ate some spicy
chips you know we've had a kind of a
tough day
uh
[Laughter]
why spicy makes people gay yeah i wanted
to see man if you would still be willing
to take me fishing i'm sorry about the
phone number thing man it was an
accident and it was my fault
but um but yeah i was gonna come maybe
uh into this week or next week
if you if you still wanted to go man i'd
love to go one day
and also sorry uh if you flip your phone
vertical you'll be able to see brendan
theo
should there we go oh yeah
yeah sorry about that man yeah i just
wanted to apologize man it was an
accident
and and if it messed up your phone or
anything you know i'd be more than
willing to pay for your phone bill or do
whatever to help out
right you will do give them a new phone
i would just love to say you have some
great fans and you also have some real
weirdos oh did you get some weird text
brother
yeah ben from south carolina uh
definitely a weirdo
no no no uh penis picks that's where i
was gonna draw the line and change my
number but i didn't get any of those do
you get any suicidal threats
anything like that oh no not suicidal
uh theo mentioned i was either a nice
guy or a murderer
and some people were trying to like put
that to the test
seeing if i would come kill them
it is just some weird stuff yeah yeah
that seems that's almost asian in a lot
of ways
yeah dude i'm just north of nashville
from where you've probably been hanging
out yeah um and yeah i'd love to hang
out dude we got some good spots me and
one of my buddies love to go
um just chill out relax by the water so
yeah that'd be a great time man
yeah man well i'll hit you up then uh
i'll text you whenever we get done with
the show today but um
but yeah there's no checks right
yeah no chicks probably but yeah but we
can talk about them you know we can talk
about chicks and
you can show pictures and yeah we're
getting that pic we have have them in
our in our heads while we're out there
but no man i'm looking forward to it
dude i'd love to get out there and do
some fishing so i appreciate it and
and yeah man if you still take me man
i'll go out there with you guys uh
yeah this week or next week just
whenever you guys go again
yeah for sure brother be great cool man
well i appreciate it yeah
sorry again man yeah and i guess there's
a lot of freaks out there a lot of
perverts i know that
i just let my number accidentally on uh
last week's king in this game
oh what happened uh i i just put it up
on the screen and the screen record it
was when we were looking at the uh
the eggs in that and it like auto
populated the thing
i had some people hitting me i've left
mine before and uh
i've gotten hundreds of texts from
people some there's a man that will not
leave me alone
[Laughter]
is it the dude from south carolina ben i
don't know i haven't looked at the air
with the area code is but
but yeah man sorry about that and yeah
i'm looking forward to it dude so we'll
go uh i'll hit you up i'll drop you a
text whenever i get done and we'll go uh
this week or next week next time you
guys are free yeah sounds good
brother all right we appreciate it man
thank you for your patience see you man
damn all right cheers i was gonna ask
what species of fish they catch there
oh he's still there oh you saw that just
all the bass man some crappie maybe
oh [ __ ] sweet want your butt
want you boys quit being gang go
noodling get your hands dirty dawg
get in there some catfish man crappie's
the ticket
well he's in the gay part but maybe yeah
hey man that's what i'm saying bro
noodling on ladies get your shirts off
start
noodling dog well hannah baron's gonna
come on uh this past weekend and
sometime
next month so maybe after she sees this
maybe we can get her to go uh fishing
with us one day
yeah let's do it that'd be crazy but uh
she's doing elk hunting or something
right now damn she killing elk i guess
she's gonna kill her what we should do
is when i go to nashville we drive down
and
shoot [ __ ] with hannah oh that'd be
crazy maybe she'll come up then
but yeah man i'll i'll hitch up and
we'll go man i'm excited i'm ready to go
i'm ready to go get on some my insides
are good
all right be good brother have a good
one appreciate you cheers man thank you
the king of nice